elle est passée à côté de moi sans un
regard plein de sava ina japon que c'est
pour toi aussi les bijoux les fruits
bien mûrs au bout de bienne m'a dit
aïcha si tu m'aimes
[Applaudissements]
est elle si elle fait adore recherchait
ve
à mon avis ça va ça va très dans le sang
jeudi en sortant du radeau flottera
alors parce qu'on aura de deux 2
candidats de noyade la semaine dernière
qui viendront tout nu sur ce plateau
c'est toujours un bonheur d'avoir deux
ou trois personnes maintenues ça fait
toujours un petit peu d'ambiance un
petit peu de piquant sur toi côtés de
nelson monfort je vois une quête de nos
invités et nelson monfort
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci des fluctuations elle m'a dit
comment ça ma famille est là nicolas bon
on va revenir à bien sûr sûr sûr votre
aventure puisque ce soit il y aura donc
recherché vous avez eu cette bosse tous
les deux non mais franchement
et puis cette opération camouflage là
avec on va très bien nelson auriez dû
dire qu'après quand vous aurez
heureusement que vous avez éviter
justement là l'inversion des rôles a
commencé vraiment d'elle ça va être un
très habile à lui c'est un fou de col
roulé je le connais il adore ça allait
nora et del sol ah oui elle fait très
bien partout oui effectivement regarder
l'épisode toujours classe a alors dit
moi alors oui alors et doit rentrer dans
la tête rentrée dans la pièce rentrer
dans le jeu leur entrée dans la pièce
allez-y retrait retrait il y à des
serpents il y a des mygales il va
falloir que vous formiez une phrase en
trouvant des mots sous les mygales et
les serpents
si vous arrivez à le faire et bien un ou
téléspectateur gagnera une console de
jeu et nora et nelson c'est parti et
laura vous pouvez laisser tomber les
clés c'est parti on y va essayer de
trouver allez on y va
ce qu'il faut essayer de trouver sous
les animaux la démo c'est que vous avez
les mots vous allez devoir trouver une
phrase d'accord allez y en aura
moi je vais je bien commencé les cours
plus que je vais déjà faire les aidera
live alors re sic et leur a donc soulève
un de ses amis jaune et blanc mais pas
non mais si c'est en dessous que ça je
deviens toi je n'ai pas le courage de
mettre ma main dans le sac au delà on
voit pas ce qu'il a il ya une sorte
d'énorme a rien dans la vie des
adolescents miley cyrus a vendu ce genre
de show pré jour je veux bien
braouezec pas collé dessus mais sony
pour m'aider je t'aime
dyson qui va aller à delson hydrologie
vais j'y vais j'ai vraiment bon sens
vous y allez la dette sociale
jg je veux vas-y vas-y giné jeunes et
des toits qui ne tient rien du tout
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi alors des charges secteur des
serpents non je n'ai pas peur des
charbons ces gamins
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]